We have this tiny house on our farm,
which brings a considerable side income for us.
And today we have a hiking couple coming in.
So I'm setting up this cute couples game for them.
Also adding a bottle of wine.
This cute game comes with instructions
and two white boards to write your answers on
the pens and all the question cards.
Some of these questions are so funny.
Thank you. It's a great game to get to know each other as a couple,
to make a perfect gift for someone who just got married
or for an anniversary getaway.
I can't wait to see what the couple said about this game.
And I'm sure they had such a laugh with it.
So let's get back to finishing the RV
and getting it ready for their arrival.
Click the link to grab yours.